you're descended from indigenous people
yeah boniato you're a man before
settlement Australia looking more like
Europe right yeah it was like you know
350 to 500 nations language groups I
know you have a lot of tattoos on your
arms Yeah right well can you tell us
what these are about because these are
important to you
I got crusty oh that's pretty god I
thought I was about to see this ancient
symbol we go to back 3,000 years it
represents your dear people and no rusty
the clam 31 seasons we get on this one
oh my arms look up my tribe Yorta Yorta
Yorta Yorta man yeah and then all my
hands is always was always will be which
is like a it's a protest kind of things
I always was always will be Aboriginal
man right I just got drawn on about my
friends and this happened to be great
artists right so all these tattoos
happen when you were asleep yeah you up
you got lucky
yeah I could have had a bunch of dicks
what is it you're trying to accomplish
now it's about changing the perceptions
of what an indigenous artist can be
right you know working with people like
you know Matt Groening says a lot for
what an indigenous kid from a country
town in Victoria can achieve yes and
I'll try to give back as much as I can
as well there's no point in me winning
and doing all these stuff and if my
success doesn't reflect home did your
family understand do you have a they
don't understand what you're up to
my experience was the minute my parents
saw that I was paying my own rent they
didn't care if I was an assassin for a
living he's got a job what does he's a
male prostitute apparently he's very
good at it I think in the future of this
country I really do Thanks and of course
my opinion carries no weight here if you
spread the word that Conan thinks Briggs
is the future you could be done here
hopefully this yeah will you come see me
in LA yeah sure yeah let's keep this
going very nice Briggs good on ya okay
it's like patronizing oh so I just sort
of told you - yeah a little bit Briggs
hey welcome the ultimate cultural
ambassador
[Laughter]